grab a drink everyone deputy chopper
down with the nazis
the latest season of the crown is here
and with it absolutely brilliant
performances by olivia coleman
josh o'connor and newcomers to the
series jillian anderson as the iron lady
margaret thatcher
and of course emma corin as princess
diana in this video we'll be explaining
some of the season's biggest moments
which covers a time period from 1979 to
1990
and what it could mean for season five
remember that season five has a totally
new cast kind of like what the show did
between seasons two and three
so you want to stick around to the very
end to see who will be playing those new
roles
but before we get into it make sure to
like and subscribe i'm hoping to come
out with a separate video in the
upcoming days on the key differences
between the crown and what
actually happened in real life so you
want to be here for that it is an ending
explained so how about we start with the
very final scene of the season this is
christmas a time supposed to be filled
with joy and happiness but for princess
diana it's a prison
she's pretty much the only one in the
christmas photo not smiling cast off to
the side away from her husband and
children
just like she's cast off from the rest
of the family as she descends the stairs
the director has aligned her head with
the antlers of a mounted animal as if
she's surprised to be hung for the
enjoyment of the royal family she's the
only woman to be wearing
all black as if it's a funeral and for
her it might as well be
the last two scenes completely
foreshadow her eventual death
when philip comes to cheer her up which
doesn't really go the way he plans it to
diana tells him she's going to leave
charles to which he responds
i wouldn't do that if i why not let's
just say
i can't see it ending well for you if
that wasn't foreshadowing enough
take a look at the very final shot of
the season a solitary
camera flash camera flashes from the
paparazzi were said to have blinded the
driver of diana's car the night it
crashed
leading to the eventual death of the
princess and her lover dodi fayed
i also found it interesting that the
very last shot of the season is
juxtaposed with the very first shot that
of the queen
two close-ups of two powerful yet very
different women but to understand how
diana got to this place we must venture
back to see how her fairy tale turned
into a nightmare
diana's first encounter with the prince
dressed as a mad tree from shakespeare's
a midsummer night's stream
didn't actually happen although it's a
nice throwback to how charles wanted to
become an actor
in reality charles met diana at a
hunting weekend when she was 16 years
old and believe it or not charles and
diana met on only 13
occasions before he proposed for diana
this was a fairy tale
in fact episode 3 is called just that
she is legitimately in love with charles
and goes out celebrating with her
girlfriends
little does she know her life is about
to spin out of control
the merry-go-round behind her and
charles foreshadowing this as well as
the multiple shots of the spiral
staircase
depicting her descent into a life that
will lead to her death for charles this
is no fairy tale
whatever in love means with the love of
his life camilla parker bowles married
to another man
charles is pressured into finding
someone new to mary
pressured not only by his family but the
one he loves
you need to find yourself a young woman
who's free to be where you want when you
want
he's willing to give up her whole life
for you and diana fits this
perfectly she's a part-time cleaner
part-time kindergarten worker
who could drop everything at the drop of
a hat to be there for charles but the
event that really solidifies diana as a
front-runner for charles's hand in
marriage
is her trip to balmoral castle in
episode 2 titled the balmoral test we
see how margaret thatcher fails
miserably
diana however passes with flying colors
in the history of balmoral no one has
ever passed a test with such
flying colours even princess anne says
to charles that it's written in the
stars that they be together she did
after all help phillip catch that
elusive stag and it's philip who drives
home charles's duty to marry
made the family position painfully clear
they want me to marry her so we can see
this fairy tale is far from ideal
a young woman in love with a man who's
in love with another woman
in fact this fairy tale reference is
articulated by princess anne later in
episode 9.
once upon a time there was a beautiful
young girl who fell madly in love with a
henson prince
unfortunately the prince was already in
love with someone else who was herself
in love with someone else and they all
lived unhappily ever after charles
himself cries on the evening of his
wedding
juxtaposed to the celebratory fireworks
in the background
although unsubstantiated it is said that
charles told diana the day before the
wedding he was not in love with her
she thought about leaving but went ahead
with the wedding anyway
the real disintegration of the marriage
begins when diana finds out about
charles's love for camilla during a
lunch date with her diana finds out how
much camilla knows about
charles and how little she does they
have fun nicknames for each other fred
and gladys which she'll eventually find
custom designed bracelets charles made
for camilla
they talk every day on the phone while
she can't even get a hold of him it's
not until their tour of australia
everything comes out for once the two
are brutally honest with each other so
much so that they actually patch things
up and things seem to get back on track
even charles decides not to pick up his
calls from camilla but that is
short-lived as diana takes the spotlight
on their trip
he begins to resent her for the
attention she receives while he is
mocked and made a fool one need only
look at the charles of season 3 and how
he was neglected
sent off to school and pushed into a
life that he didn't really want
to see why he now craves love and
attention because he never got that from
his family so when diana comes along and
takes that love and attention away from
him he's resentful
he resents me resents the attention i
get diana tries time and time again to
make the marriage work
but at every turn charles finds
something to get upset about
when she performs a dance for his 37th
birthday he thinks it's all about
putting attention on her
stealing the limelight from him and even
when she goes out of her way to make a
video of her singing from phantom of the
opera
with the cast of the actual west end
production he tells anne it's god awful
it's kind of ironic then when charles
cries out to anne asking what it takes
to get some kindness in this family when
he himself shows almost none to his wife
in the season's final episode charles
tries to argue to camilla that the
public would understand if he broke up
with diana
and went for camilla because he'd be
following his heart
but camilla is smart to be the
protagonist of a fairy tale you must
first be wronged
a victim the crown does a great job at
painting both charles and diana as
victims while also highlighting their
flaws diana is shown in all of her
humanity good
and bad we see her struggles with
anorexia and how she looks for love with
other men
when her husband won't give her any and
that humanity is what made her the
people's princess
evidently that clinging is what the
australians have responded to
what a natural mother she is how
physical
and caring charles however is painted
more as the villain this season perhaps
even more than margaret thatcher herself
and the iron lady presents this season
with its second major
conflict that between the queen and the
prime minister
in 1979 margaret thatcher became prime
minister as head of the conservative
party
and the queen's initial reaction was one
of promise she'd have her first female
prime minister to have weekly chats with
and what better inspiration for young
women than a strong female leader
right but i have found women in general
tend not to be suited to high offers
hey why is that they become too
emotional thatcher's nickname the iron
lady is
perfectly suited for a cold woman ruling
with an iron fist without compassion
she has a fundamentally different
approach to how the united kingdom
should be run from how it used to be
margaret thatcher was a firm believer in
reaganomics basically policies that put
emphasis on the
individual rather than the state britons
are learning to
look after number one to get ahead and
only then if they
choose to look after their neighbor the
uk at the time was going through a
recession with massive unemployment
instead of providing a robust social
safety net for those most at risk
thatcher did the opposite and cut
spending for such programs while waging
a multi-billion dollar war in the
falklands
that's what led michael fagan to break
into buckingham palace to talk with the
queen
he said the system has been so gutted
and broken he had to take drastic
measures to talk to the only person that
he thought would listen to him
thatcher's emphasis on pushing
sentimentality aside is shown in her
position on apartheid south africa
rather than side with the other 48
commonwealth nations in imposing
sanctions
all she cares about is the bottom line
the billions of dollars in trade that
would be lost
should the sanctions proceed her lack of
compassion also extends to her family as
she strongly favors her arrogant
entitled and british son
over her daughter the conflict between
the queen and the prime minister starts
when she's invited to bal moral however
it isn't until later in the season when
the queen leaks her
disapproval of the pm's decision on
south africa that it comes to a head
the queen's policy has been to never
express an opinion or pass judgment on
any of the prime ministers
so this was a big deal and as the
credits at the end of episode 8 show the
palace continues to insist
she never said the stuff michael shea
leaked to the press
in the end however thatcher and the
queen spent almost 11 years together
with roughly 164 meetings together
thatcher was in her own words cruelly
torn from her party
and forced to resign but later the queen
would bestow her with the award of merit
an honorary title first awarded by king
edward vii
in 1902 for those who provided
distinguished service to the state
although charles and anne are the more
prominent of the queen's children in the
series we also get small
cameos from princess edward and andrew
and bonus points if you caught the
absolutely creepy scene in which andrew
talks about loving a movie about an
underage girl on an island full of
perverts this was totally the show's nod
to prince andrew having been a close
friend of jeffrey epstein frequently
visiting his island of underage women
switching gears to really understand the
series one must also
understand its masterful use of
juxtaposition and double meaning or as
the french say
double entrangle i just like saying that
episode 1 sees the juxtaposition between
hunting and assassination as montbaton
is stalked and hunted by the ira
so too does the royal family engage in
the hunt
charles fishes montbaton catches lobster
and shoots the stag
and philip hunts birds episode nine's
title engages in double entendre being
called
avalanche not only is this episode about
an actual avalanche the avalanche is a
metaphor for what's happening in charles
and diana's marriage
episode 10 titled war has even more
meanings we see a war between
thatcher and her party war between
charles and diana
war between thatcher and the queen and
an actual war between britain and its
involvement in the gulf and one of the
last things i want to discuss was
who will be playing the new characters
for the final two seasons
now i should mention that the last two
seasons will likely only cover the 90s
and maybe early 2000s so for those of
you looking for william and kate
middleton
or harry and meghan markle drama you're
out of luck
so we have four confirmed castings
including imelda staunton as queen
elizabeth
jonathan price as prince philip leslie
manville as princess margaret
elizabeth de becky as princess diana and
not confirmed but rumored
dominic west as prince charles still no
word on who will play the queen's other
children
camilla parker bowles or prime ministers
john major and tony blair
who would likely be covered during this
time the new season won't be out until
2022 at the earliest so put on a cup of
tea and subscribe to my channel in the
meantime
i'm hoping to come out with another
crown video in the next few days
so be sure to stick around for that
thanks for watching everyone make sure
to like the video share
it and leave a comment about what events
you think will happen in season 5
in the comments below for more bad takes
you can follow me on twitter and
instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you